the southern city of bengaluru has
received more than 400 times the amount
of rain it usually does in november
flooding has led to the deaths of at
least 24 people in the state of
karnataka and thousands have been
stranded
emergency workers are using boats to
rescue people from their homes
from last 15 days continuous raining is
there
heavy raining is from last three days
continuous rain
now we are having nearly
four eight blocks we are having
603 flats were there nearly three
thousand people we are living here
in other parts of bengaluru many can't
get into their homes
we can't go inside the house and there's
too much water in front of it all the
groceries are inside and we've been
outside the house since last night
many people are concerned there could be
more flooding as several lakes are
overflowing
it's been more than 12 years since the
lake became full and this is the first
time it's been overloaded and the drains
have become blocked now water is
overflowing and it has rained very
heavily too
the states of andhra pradesh tamilnad
and purucheri are also badly affected
dozens of people including rescue
workers have died in andhra pradesh
where the indian air force is airlifting
people to safety
many parts of southern india are
experiencing excessive rainfall
environmentalists say unpredictable and
extreme weather across south asia is
being driven by climate change and made
worse by deforestation the construction
of dams and excessive development while
the rain has eased in the worst affected
state andhra pradesh people in tamilnadu
are preparing for more heavy downpours
elizabeth puranam al jazeera new delhi